on va sur la lutte est pas
jouer les touches appel juliette arnaud
et cristina rios
alors dans cette pièce qui s'appelle
arrête de pleurer pénélope 2 ya russie
corinne puget mais l'appel doit de
sortir le cézanne nom et à lyon donc
elle a alors sauté à deux fontaines à
partir du 19 septembre
oui et ou festivals avignon pendant tout
le match d'hier lui tu avignon cet été
alors voilà
mise en scène de michèle bernier
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez vous dire
pourquoi ils n'ont codes de la pièce
double peiné à d'accord l'assassiner on
est malade mais je pense que robin a
adoré mais qui se dit plus rien ouais
donc cet été à avignon à la rentrée au
théâtre fontaine et voilà et la suite d'
arrête de pleurer pénélope puisqu'elle
est jean il a bien marché
oui oui oui on peut dire ça a bien
marché a bien marché alors on revient
alors pour mettre les listes javel roues
du tout
alors on connaît tous et ça c'est la
musique de les yeux dans les bleus
ou pas
oui
ban
ça s'est su baisse ce qui n'est pas
encore la fin de vie et non pas en
générique de fin on tombera original
soundtrack
voilà qui est votre nouvelle nouvel
album qui sort laquelle si heavy reading
les enfants donc je veux l'interprète de
bach jouée par équipes c'est l'équipe de
pascal olmeta côtés de françois berléand
et après ce sera le chacun pour sa
gueule on y va odudu c'est parti
et un noir we were four et au moulin
qui a composé cette chanson a donc pas
ni à un jeu non
alors le point elle annoncé lundi
parce que je suis car on continue
roudoudou attention concentre toi
françois non
la queue
faux
la mère vacharde
carter
à part
g
george harrison
la chute jeudi les beatles les doors el
arish jeudi les buts je sais pas mais
enfin il est temps pareil c'est pas
pareil comment c'est pas pareil bien sûr
j'ai papa il aimerait jouer de l'est
très dur
je serai là jeanne elle dit tous sont
persuadés oui
c'est vachement dur c'est exceptionnel
c'est magical mystery d'or et ça
s'appelle blue jay way et c'était
l'adresse de george harrison à los
angeles
il faut être très très âgées pour
connaître ça bien bien soir moi je joue
un peu plus jeunes maintenant à petit
bâtard
à
le prix en france et part à ce choc 4,6
lui marquant bravo exactement très bien
rond continuer ou doudou
hier
c'est pas demain
énorme c'est bon
donc ça fait un point pour l'équipe de
pascal olmeta trois points pour l'équipe
de françois berléand
non
j'ai moi aussi j'étais de l'autre côté
avant goût du tout
pauline ester
non vraiment c'est la nouvelle toiture
on écoute tu peux pas c'est que je
confirme je compris alors
mais pour vous mesdames les sacs à dos
ont frappé deux fois pour l'équipe ii le
métal trois points pour l'équipe de
france sommes en vérité ces 1/4 boudou
bravo j'ai effectivement les réveille un
peu connue quand même
je vais quand même ça le poivre le kid
de berne est entachée non c'est gilles
un qui sait gym c'est toi le capitaine
de l'équipe c'est presque comme si lad
même c'est lui qui marque le capitaine
un peu oui et non il était pour la nonne
ont été bons l'ouest non c'est l'image
de l'autre qui se casse la jambe et 6
ans tu fais place des bleus parker weeds
qui marquerait la servir d'excusé ça
pour pas gagner le mondial
l'or
voilà ses oreilles si loin pour les
villes de berne heures chaque nous c'est
quand même solution d'ici
bassil
makengo lois déloyales donc il est quand
même très vieux et il fait des choses
énormes artistes jacques nos grands
ouais c'est dur à guam qu'est ce que tu
fais ta salade
il regarde nabias n'imagine pas pareil
vu sous blason
il ya eu soufflage de points bas là
je suis je suis un putois est
impitoyable de rectitude mois alors voir
mais je ne sais pas des damnés quand
même d'animer le point là n'ont rien dit
eux qui les dépasse celle de cette
infernale parce que ils ne disent rien
des pointes de toiras le mantois temps
mais cette savane mauvaise foi terrible
locales issues du par équipes trois
points pour l'équipe de pascal olmeta et
sept mois
paul hegy de renforts
ok
et maintenant les cieux nous passons au
chacun pour sa gueule il ya plus
l'équipe
voilà un coup et ça et 7 ans c'est le
libéralisme luc raval sauvage plus
d'amis on piétine ses amis allons-y à
toi redoute ou nadia
bois pour juliette un truc du marais
c'est très dur ce qui arrive très très
dur moi même je sais pas si je le show
rodé
non
non mr non j'ai que dès que son jardin
son bras
grand frère bref tu l'avais choisi gens
ça on continue le méga bande ku mains
encore du mal à trouver leur lançant un
bonne nuit
jusqu'à présent je pense que juliette
est grande gagnante de la soirée et on
arrive à l'ultra bon call ces normes que
des gens qui trouvent du travail où il a
très très peu
odudu
l'évasion
mais voilà brigitte fontaine bravo au
pyla sur mer
oui on arrive à l'origine gabon co voilà
et c'est là où la vie est également
colas était gentil entre la marraine
d'amazon ian lauzon vous
à
les faits
voilà bravo gilles nom du net en a deux
fois plus naturel cigarettes aux étoiles
et vous voilà bah ouais ben non il est
vrai que j'aime bien c'est un truc un
truc vraiment impossible
bof c'est pas pour moi tant pas juste
comme ça
vas-y
bravo je préfère battre en scène a fait
des voyages
moi
non
fischer
ici là et là bas
voilà j'arrive pas le diamant faux nom
si c'est moi qui composaient c'est moi
c'est toi richard petit oui parce que
c'est mon nom mon front c'était du moins
lampard